one time in high school I said I'm ready
to read Ulysses he said Jonathan you're
really not ready for Ulysses you can't
handle Ulysses
that's okay Dad fine so he's dead I'm
now probably 60 and my little librarian
Maine which looks like this room in the
pull-up and I'm getting very sentimental
because I got a chair that was his chair
that when he was given this special
chair and it's got this is Lehigh
University in the back and I'm sitting
in Dad's chair and I take you the dog
ear do list he's out of the thing that I
said I thought this would be a great
moment if I have a moment with my dead
dad I hope he'll do about two paragraphs
and I've lost completely out of
my Realm and I said yeah you're right
you can't handle you listening I'm 62
years old I put the book back